[Applaudissements]
il est 20h40 on est en direct bien
entendu dans tespmp 20h41 maintenant on
va passer au boss du jour il concerne un
rappeur et acteur français Sadek
dimanche matin aprèsavoir pris la fuite
l'artiste a été interpellé pu placé en
garde à vu on va vous apprendre tout ce
qui s'est passé sur cette affaire plus
de 2,2 million de vues sur la vidéo hein
aujourd'hui c'était un truc de fou tout
le monde en a parlé petit récap et
Miriam Palomba et Reda bellage Miriam
Palomba donc spécialiste des sauces et
Reda bellage porte-parole unitép police
seront avec nous pour tout nous
expliquer de cette nouvelle so c'est
parti depuis le début des années 2010
Sadek a su se faire un nom dans le
milieu du rap français S c'est de la
dynamite et alors que le rappeur de 32
ans touché par une période de dépression
avait récemment indiqué avoir arrêté
l'alcool et la drogue l'alcoolisme j'
j'en suis sorti parce que je m'en suis
rendu compte l'homme aurait été contrôlé
positif à l'alcool et à la cocaïne hier
matin alors qu'il venait d'être arrêté
en tentant de prendre la fuite après un
accident de la route alors le rappeur
Sadek aurait commis un délit de fuite
sous l'emprise de la drogue et de
l'alcool que s'est-il
passé que s'est-il passé bien on arrê d'
bellage merci d'être avec nous
porte-parole unitégp police merci d'être
là et ah
bah avir un petit but
maintenant écoutez on se refuse
rien il est arrivé avec ses deux petites
feuilleselle là voilà la spécialiste des
sauces la sace GRIB comment on l'appelle
dans le
métier merci Myriam Palomba merci d'être
là on va voir la version de Myriam bien
sûr la version j'ai envie de dire people
et puis on va voir la version police de
Reda Béage myiam alors ou passé qui est
alors déjà qui est Sadec pour les
téléspectateurs parce qu'il y en a plein
qui ne connaissent pas ici je crois que
Jacques cardose alors c'est un rappeur
qui a 32 ans qui est très connu dans le
dans dans le milieu du Hipop il a déjà
été disque d'or pour pour pour un pour
un album qui a fait fait il est très
très connu il a il aussi fait des
collaborations au cinéma notamment avec
un drle il est d' avec autre acteur qui
est dans la sauce aussi mais Gérard de
pardieu
mais alors personne n'est dans la sace
alors vous parlez de deux poes Gérard de
pardieu et et Sadek voilà voilà donc
donc voilà donc Sadek donc un rappeur de
32 ans qui qui qui est né dans le
3 à PL SaintDenis et voilà qui est très
connu du milieu
Hipop merci Salut
euh qu'est-ce qui s'est passé alors en
fait dimanche vers vers 9h près du
boulevard près du 127 boulevard de la
Villette dans dans le 19e al vous êtes
la seule meuf qui dit prêt mais avec une
adresse précise ou par qu'on
l'ANT être précis à Paris d'c voilà donc
dans le 19e berb d'accord voilà donc
dans le dans le 19e arrondissement de
Paris donc vers 9h il y a deux voitures
qui rentrent en collision et là il y a
un aut automobiliste qui prend la fuite
à pied le deuxième automobiliste décide
d'appeler donc la police là une
patrouille arrive en urgence et et en
fait se met à chercher dans les environs
et ils arrêtent donc ce sadcin ce
rappeur et ils lui font ils le testent
et il s'aperçoivent que il est sous
emprise de cocaïne et d'alcool donc
d'élit fite accident et enem prise de de
cocaïne enfin et sousemprise de cocaïne
et d'alcool et donc il a été placé immé
imatement garde à vue dans dans le dans
le commissariat du 10e arrondissement
notamment spécialisé pour tout ce qui
est trafic de drogue et et TTI quenti
toutti quanti d'accord euh aujourd'hui
donc il est toujours en garde à vue
alors il est toujours en garde à vue
parce qu' en fait au-delà du délit de
fuite et de l'accident il y a aussi des
soupçons de de trafic de drogue donc
c'est pour ça qu'ilpon attention ne
prenez pas votre rôle trop voilà c'est
ça parce que vous vous mettez les gens
dans dans d'autres sauces non
c'est j'ai rien contre enfin j'aimerais
d'ailleurs préciser que que souvent je
me fais sur les réseaux sociaux j'ai
rien contre les gens moi je vous fais du
factuel donc voilà ce qu'il en est donc
ça ça sa garde à vue a été prolongée de
24 heur et et donc on va vite savoir ce
que décide le juge d'instruction dans
cette affaire alors Reda merci d'être là
il y a eu un déite fit c'est comment on
peut affirmer queil s'agit d'un déite
fit euh bah à partir du moment où vous
avez un accident et que la personne
volontairement voilà prend la fuite
exactement ce qui s'est passé
merci la personne ne reste pas non mais
c'est important parce que vous savez
qu'on a une justice qui est très
pointilleuse bien sûr et des fois il
suffit de même parler avec le le le la
personne avec qui on a un accident ça
peut être considéré comme comme non
délit fite non donc non mais
l'infraction il faut qu'elle soit
vraiment caractérisée si la personne
elle prend contact avec le le l'autre
victime on va dire entre guillemets euh
bah la fraction n'est plus caractérisée
il faut vraiment qu'il y ait aucun
contact et queaccord jeiment pas de
contact à part des contacts bien sûr
auveau automobile euh qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé exactement alors euh bah
qu'elle a dit c'est exactement ce
qu'elle a dit il faut savoir Queel été
contrôlé déjà la semaine dernière euh
avec une personne qui était des qui
avait des produits stupéfiants sur elle
elle a pas été inquiétée enfin Monsieur
Sadek en tout cas inquiété et il est
connu défavorablement des services tu as
une affaire au moins une affaire de de
tabassage sur un
youtu il a en 2020 en fait il a il a il
a comment s'appelle il a tabassé un
blogueur lyonnais euh voilà parce que il
l'avait critiqué et avait avait dit aux
gens de ne pas se rendre à son concert
donc ça s'était fini à coup de de bat de
baseball et à l'époque il avait été mis
en détention pour provisoire
d'ailleurs cette affaire a été un peu
classée enfin il a pas eu vraiment de
condamnation à ce moment-là alors euh
vous Reda donc aujourd'hui il est
toujours en garde à vue oui il est
toujours en garde à vue alors le motif
en tout cas moi en tant que représentant
syndical je peux pas pas le dire ça peut
être aussi bien pour elle va le dire une
affaire c'est plus ou moins c'est plus
ou moins ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure
je pense que vous voulez ceon peut dire
c'est il peut y avoir une incidente ou
alors ça peut être aussi euh
le fait qu'il ne reconnaissent pas du
tout les faits parce que le fait qu'
quité ce que je vous dis c'est très
c'est des affaires qui sont quand même
assez pointilleux mais il était il était
violent l'accident qui eu alors il y a
pas enfin les voitures sont accidentées
après il y a pas eu de de blessés grave
et il y a certainement pas de de
circonstances aggravante pouvant
entraîner des ITT dans cet accident donc
vous ce que vous avez dit vous a donc ce
qui veut pas dire c'est quoi bah c'est
que certainement il il le garde parce
que il y a soupçon de trafic de drogue
ah d'accord d'accord ouais alors il veut
pas le dire donc il le dira pas r RA
vous l'avez jamais dit ici et je peux
vous dire jamais personne me dira vous
avez dit ça vous avez rien dit
euh il est donc arrêté pour accident de
la route dit fit et positif à l'alcool
et à la cocaïne pour l'instant alors
pour le coup il a des circonstances sans
vouloir vous voilà il a des
circonstances aggravantes parce qu'il
risque quand même une amende de 75000 €
et 3 ans d'emprisonnement pour la
conduite en état d'ivresse ouais et euh
6 points sur le permis mais son je pense
que c'est le cadet de ses souciis après
vous avez ça c'est pour le Delite fit
pardon et pour la conduite sous sous
empire d'alcool il risque une peine de 4
ans avec 90000 € et 4500 € pour le Stup
et 2 ans et une annulation de permis
euh à la suite de la garde à vue il va
il va se passer quoi alors il y a deux
deux options donc à la fin de la garde à
vue l'officier de police judiciaire va
aviser le parquet et le procureur le
parquet va décider s'il est déféré ou
pas par rapport à ses antécédents par
rapport à ce qu'il dit dans son audition
et puis et puis il risque de faire de la
prison ferme ou alors il peut on peut
décider qu'il soit libre donc oui c'est
vrai que par rapport à l'affaire
précédente il avait fait un mois et demi
de détention de 2020 oui et il avait été
mis en examen sous contrôle judiciaire
mais il n'avait pas de bracelet
électronique c'est important de le
préciser et cette affaire effectivement
pour le moment à notre connaissance n'a
pas été jugé alors que c'était quand
même un tabassage qui avait fait
beaucoup de bruit à l'époque on en avait
parlé voilà sur un blogueur qui
remettait en cause un de ses concerts il
avait empêché de faire un concert donc
ils avaient monté une expédition et
voilà oui on s'est B ça fait 15 fois
qu'on le dit arrête pas de le dire dans
l'oreille on sait qui c'est non il en
n'est pas son premier déit fit a priori
il a avoué lui-même dans une interview
qu'il avait déjà commis un déit fit il y
a quelques années et c'est quelqu'un qui
dans ses chansons bon comme beaucoup de
rappeurs mais prô de la consommation
d'alcool et de drogue au volant il y a
même un de ces clips un de ces derniers
clips qui commence par un accident de
voiture avec un chauffeur qui a pris un
un ballon d'azote donc malheureusement
on voit que les fantasmes un peu des
clips de rap là se transposent dans la
vraie vie et j'espère que ces fans
suivront pas mais non puis ce qui asse
terrible c'est que c'est quand même
quelqu'un qui qui a lui-même été victime
très jeune à l'âge de 11 ans d'un
accident de voiture qui l'a beaucoup euh
handicapé donc visiblement ça lui a pas
servi de leçon alors justement c'est fou
parce que ça arrive encore à chaque fois
on va on va en parler dans un instant
parce que on va passer aussi à l'autre
affaire avec Marwan Beren qui
apparemment lui aussi a fait percuter
quelqu'un sur la route on va voir dans
témoignage dans un instant mais on a
l'impression que c'est vrai que c'est
c'est ça fait trois affaires maintenant
qui qui succèd comme ça de de de
personnalités qui qui font des délit
suite alors aujourd'hui la problématique
à laquelle on doit faire c'est que avec
les réseaux sociaux tout va très très
vite des fois les les journalistes
savent les choses même avant nous
représentant du personnel la preuve on
est on a la preuve devant nous et on
cloisonne en fait enfin on essaie de
cloisonner un maximum et de on a pour
instruction de donner un minimum
d'information un peu comme si c'était du
secret défense pour protéger euh les
auteurs présumés et voilà c'est c'est
c'est c'est une chose à lesquel on doit
faire de plus en plus face on l'a vu
dans l'affaire Guillon on l' vu dans G
j'ai une question à poser à à Reda il y
a beaucoup de personnalités
effectivement qui commettent des délit
suite on se souvient de Benoît Magimel
dans le passé et cetera et je je relis
pas le cas de benoî Magimel à ce que je
vais vous demander mais par dit il a il
a eu de César oui oui oui oui non mais
ce que je veux dire c'est que parfois on
me dit que des personnalités cherchent à
s'enfuir justement parce qu'elles savent
qu'elles vont être positif et à gagner
du temps aller se cacher pour que
l'effet de alcool et ou des stupéfiants
disparaissent est-ce que c'est vrai
selon votre expérience euh oui des très
très très souvent même vous avez une
personne qui va être coopt voir
indemnisé pour se faire passer pour le
chauffeur donc c'est peut-être ce qu'il
avait je sais pas je veux pas juger mais
bah oui parce que comme ça qu'il est
devenu chauffeur livreur non je rig
parce que pour le coup si il faisait
l'objet de d'autres infractions bah il
risque il a plus de chance d'être
condamné en tout cas voilà il y a pas eu
de en tout cas de il y a pas eu de de
blessé grave non il a juste pris peur
pourquoi il a pris peur bah parce non il
a pris peur parce qu'il savait qu'il
restait de la prison de la prison ferme
et vous savez je pense que même si c'est
un accident matériel je pense que si ça
avait été un accident corporel ou plus
grave comme on l' vu dans laffire
Palmade tout simplement je pense que
cette personne elle aurait pris la fuite
de encore plus et on en est où
d'ailleurs de l'affire Palmade laffire
Palmade bah là il y a y a le procès
normalement devrait se dérouler en
2024 donc donc voilà c'est toujours
c'est toujours en cours lui il est
toujours Bordeaux en faisant des
allers-retours entre les soins de
l'hôpital de de Bordeaux de toxicologie
et puis et puis là où yvit près de chez
sa maman merci on va passer tout de
suite au